(instrumental music)
- I am Ernestine
Shepherd, 80 years of age.
(upbeat instrumental music)
I bench press 110 pounds.
I started training at age 71.
I was named the oldest female
competitive body builder
at the Guinness Book of World Records.
My sister and I started
exercising together.
I had never done any type
of exercising before.
Before she died, she said, promise me
you will follow my dream and try to get
in the Guinness Book of World Records.
So, that's what I did.
(upbeat instrumental music)
I have been in six or seven competitions.
I win, but some I come
out second and third,
and I'm pleased with that.
(upbeat instrumental music)
I'm up every morning at 2:30.
After I have my devotions, I walk
and I run approximately 10 miles.
I'm at the gym at 7:30, and I have
a group of ladies that I train.
Down, and one.
I train all ages.
One of the youngest, I think
she's about 20 years of age,
and the rest go from 40,
all the way up to 80.
(cheering and applause)
When people come to my class
for the very first time,
they are really, really surprised.
They said, "I didn't think this exercise
"would be this tough,
but if you can do it,
"we are going to do it, too."
I really don't feel as
though I'm 80 years of age,
but I am!
I want to keep training
until my day is done.
(instrumental music)